[Música]
en Brasil el Tribunal Superior electoral
advirtió que serán castigados aquellos
que nieguen los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales entre tanto la
policía Busca desbloquear las
movilizaciones que han paralizado varias
vías en algunas ciudades del país por
cuatro días consecutivos
en Colombia Después de tres meses de
negociaciones El Congreso aprobó la
reforma tributaria que propuso el
gobierno del presidente Gustavo Petro
con ella el gobierno colombiano espera
recaudar 4 mil millones de dólares en el
año 2023
y en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo
lasso en un mensaje a la nación afirmó
que la policía y el ejército recuperaron
el control de la penitenciaría del
litoral en la ciudad de Guayaquil esto
después de que se presentaran disturbios
en donde seis militares y dos policías
resultaron heridos varios sectores
reclaman al gobierno nacional más
políticas para garantizar seguridad
Bienvenidos a este informativo de France
24 en el que les contamos las
principales noticias de nuestro
continente el continente americano vamos
a comenzar en Brasil allí el presidente
del tribunal superior electoral condenó
los actos antidemocráticos de Seguidores
del presidente Jair bolsonaro quienes
pidieron una intervención militar el tse
advirtió sobre castigos Según la ley
para los responsables mientras se
diluyen los movimientos de protesta los
miembros del equipo de Lula y de
bolsonaro se reunieron para iniciar el
traspaso de Mando
la democracia ganó en Brasil eso afirmó
el presidente del tribunal superior
electoral Alessandra de moraes quien
instó a los seguidores bolsonaristas a
Cesar los movimientos de protesta por
los resultados en los comicios del
domingo y advirtió con iniciar procesos
penales a los autores
las elecciones terminaron el ganador se
investirá el 19 de diciembre y asumir el
cargo el 1 de enero de 2023 estos
democracia esto es alternancia de poder
Este es el estado republicano No hay
forma de impugnar un resultado
publicitado democráticamente los
responsables de estos movimientos
antidemocráticos serán investigados y
responsabilizados con base en la ley las
manifestaciones que incluyeron bloqueos
de camiones y hasta un período de
intervención militar en la puerta de
cuarteles en decenas de ciudades
disminuyeron luego de que el propio Jair
bolsonaro las desalentara el miércoles
por la noche
en tanto que los equipos de bolsonaro y
Lula iniciaron la transición de gobierno
nuestra tarea fue nuestro trabajo es
unir a Brasil trabajar y tener una
agenda de propuestas para mejorar la
vida de las personas sigamos adelante la
transición comenzó y la haremos de la
mejor manera posible
las reuniones contaron con la presencia
de almin el coordinador de campaña de
Lula y disputados izquierdistas junto al
responsable de la propuesta del
presupuesto para 2023 y el jefe de
gabinete de bolsonaro las reuniones dan
inicio al proceso que finalizará con la
toma de Posesión del nuevo presidente el
primero de enero y Mientras tanto en
Colombia Después de tres meses de
negociaciones El Congreso de ese país
aprobó la reforma tributaria que propuso
el gobierno del presidente Gustavo Petro
con esta reforma el gobierno colombiano
espera recaudar 4 mil millones de
dólares para el año 2023 con los que
busca hacer frente a grandes
dificultades económicas con las que
viven algunos sectores de la sociedad y
también cumplir con algunas exigencias
de la ocde
es considerada la reforma más progresiva
de la historia de Colombia la tributaria
Calcula recaudar en 2023 unos 4.000
millones de dólares con los que el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro Busca poder
financiar programas sociales para
lograrlo la reforma se ha centrado en
aumentar impuestos a las personas de
altos ingresos se reduce en los
beneficios Fiscales para empresas se
tributa a las bebidas azucaradas y al
sector minero energético con sobretasas
y con la no deducibilidad de regalías y
se aumentarán recursos y esfuerzos en la
lucha contra la ilusión y la evasión
pero durante tres meses de negociaciones
también ha habido renuncias y es que el
plan inicial del gobierno era recaudar
mil millones de dólares más de los
logrados dinero perdido en la no
inclusión de los impuestos a las
iglesias a ultraprocesados como el pan
la leche la miel o las obleas
compuestos a pensiones altas
de hecho pasar esta reforma ha sido una
obsesión para el presidente el 8 de
agosto Un día después de la jura de
Posesión se presentó el proyecto con
tres objetivos sociales específicos que
son erradicar el hambre reducir la
pobreza y desmontar los tratamientos
tributarios preferenciales
pero también ha encontrado la oposición
de sectores de las clases privilegiadas
y medias en pleno aumento de la
inflación y con la devaluación de la
moneda esto con distintas protestas y
con el centro democrático principal
partido de oposición asegurando que
demandarán la Reforma por considerar la
inconstitucional
la ocde lleva tiempo insistiendo en la
necesidad de una reforma en Colombia y
dio el visto bueno a la de Gustavo Petro
después de que el Antiguo gobierno de
Iván Duque viviese Las mayores protestas
en décadas cuando trató de impulsar su
reforma tributaria con un carácter más
regresivo e impositivo en las clases
medias y bajas
pasemos ahora al vecino Ecuador en donde
los reclusos de la penitenciaría del
litoral considerada la más violenta de
Ecuador recibieron con disparos y
granadas a cientos de policías y
militares que llegaron hasta el lugar
para retomar el control de las
instalaciones de acuerdo con información
del servicio nacional de atención a
personas privadas de la libertad seis
policías y dos militares resultaron
heridos en el intento por recuperar el
control de esta cárcel que sirve a la
ciudad de Guayaquil que es la segunda
ciudad de importancia en Ecuador y hasta
donde fueron desplegados
2.600 uniformados el presidente
Guillermo lasso en un corto mensaje a la
nación afirmó que fue recuperado por
completo el control de este ubicado en
Guayaquil escuchemos
hemos tomado control de la penitenciaría
pero aún tenemos camino por recorrer y
tenemos que recorrerlo juntos Unidos
quiero agradecerles sus muestras de
apoyo y solidaridad ahora los convoco a
quienes quieren bien al país a unirse a
esta Cruzada por el Ecuador a lo largo
de esta semana los hemos llevado a
través del corazón de Estados Unidos
para ver más de cerca los temas que
decidirán esas elecciones de medio
término que son previstas para el 8 de
noviembre para el episodio número 4 nos
vamos a dirigir hasta el Sur del país a
la ciudad de Memphis en el estado de
Tennessee que tiene la segunda tasa de
pobreza más alta entre el grupo de
ciudades de más de 500 mil habitantes y
está ubicada justamente en uno de los
estados más pobres de la nación la
pandemia de Kobe 19 y ahora también
crecientes tasas de inflación empeoran
las cosas veamos
la cuna del blues se vio muy afectada
por la pandemia ahora Memphis y sus
residentes tienen que lidiar con la
inflación San y dirige un servicio de
automóviles en la ciudad
Hola Jennifer soy Sandy desfax limusin
estaba llamando para confirmar tu
recogida hoy a las 3 en punto por
primera vez en 20 años Tuvo que aumentar
sus tarifas por hora en 15 dólares
debido al aumento de los precios de la
gasolina
no es solo la gasolina el seguro subió
el precio de los autos subió incluso las
bebidas que ponemos en los vehículos
para los clientes eso también subió la
servilletas todo subió
la inflación ha empeorado tanto las
cosas que ahora está considerando vender
su empresa por ahora sin embargo trata
de mantener su factura de gas lo más
baja posible
probaremos esta gasolinera shell al
menos debería obtener 5 centavos de
descuento ahora usamos diferentes
tarjetas de crédito que nos dan
descuentos por galón la regular es
bastante buena cuesta 3.79 dólares en el
sur la inflación alcanzó casi el 9%
interanual en septiembre casi medio
punto porcentual por encima de la tasa
nacional
con 30 dólares podría llenarlo Y ahora
estás buscando de 58 a 60 para llenarlo
culpa los demócratas por sus problemas
cada vez que hemos tenido un presidente
republicano parece que al país le está
yendo muy bien a pesar de todos sus
problemas Trump dirigió el país como un
negocio y funcionó para nosotros la
inflación no solo es dura para las
pequeñas empresas también está causando
estragos entre los agricultores Marvin
rody cultiva soja en las afueras de
Memphis en El delta del Mississippi pero
este año está operando con pérdidas
cultivo aproximadamente 121 hectáreas y
mis costos operativos pasaron de
aproximadamente de 200 dólares por
hectárea a 320 dólares por hectárea
solo quiero poder producir algo de
calidad y tratar de obtener una ganancia
para pagar nuestras facturas como
agricultores
la inflación ha empeorado desde la
guerra en Ucrania los precios del diesel
y los fertilizantes se han duplicado
para mantenerse a flote rodi ha llegado
a depender de sus compañeros granjeros
Tratamos de utilizar algunos equipos que
yo pueda tener y que él lo tiene
en lugar de que ambos compremos las
mismas cosas
ya sabes solo Tratamos de reducir costos
encuestas recientes han mostrado
consistentemente que la economía y la
inflación son por mucho la prioridad
número uno para los votantes
estadounidenses y entre esos votantes la
mayoría confía más en los republicanos
para arreglar dichos problemas
llegamos al final de las noticias siga
con nosotros
[Música]